I wasn't looking to make any built
guides in your time soon because there
are thousands of them out there all
working towards the absolute min max
detail for any situation but I've been
talking to a number of people that are
struggling in the early stages of the
raid both of my squad and on other
platforms they have no idea where to
start so I've been putting together a
simple cheat sheet of sorts to help
people with what they need to prepare
for the raid I wasn't intending to make
a video for it however it does make it a
little bit easy to explain this way in
the super quick video I hope to give
first-time Raiders who are struggling to
get past the first boss on this raid and
easy to understand starting point for
the build q intro
[Music]
okay enough of that
let's crack into it this raid is all
about DPS builds and this is true all
the way through but for the purpose of
this video we're just gonna focus on the
first boss boomer on the screen right
now is a summary of what I'll be talking
about for the remainder of the video so
if you weren't wondering why I picked
these talents etc you could probably
just take a screenshot and leave
otherwise I'll carry on when it first
stepped into the raid I thought my
tried-and-true PvE build that was able
to carry me through any old heroic
content Solo would be more than capable
truth be told it was reasonably DPS
heavy so if everyone is running
something similar we may have been okay
but this wasn't the case most of us up
until now have been able to run through
the most difficult content in the game
without worrying too much about their
builds to most people's surprise and in
some cases disgust they made this raid
very difficult requiring team
coordination first and built scope with
it as a close second I love this it's
completely changed the way I feel about
the division to the need to focus more
on builds was well over jus I do hope
they introduce the need for a larger
variety of builds and later rates but
that's more of a discussion for later on
as I said before you need war damage
that's it
you could add a little bit of armor and
health to if you'd like but because of
the difficulty of the enemies and the
time limit behind killing the boss you
need to act fast I'm not going to go
into the boss mechanics too much there
are plenty of videos out there on how to
do it but to sum it up the boss can only
be dropped to his knees by taking out
his bag using a turret you'll think of
in a very small window to deal as much
damage as possible to him you have to
continue with ads you have to contend
with this healing chess piece and you
only have about ten minutes to kill him
before he destroys the two turrets team
coordination is important or you would
never be able to drop them with time and
repetition this can be learnt but a few
as a team aren't doing enough damage
you'll never be taken down in time I'm
gonna keep repeating myself in hopes
that it sticks damage is king in this
raid this is more important than any
other build attribute to make this
easier to follow I'll be using a build
that are quickly threw together in a
couple of hours using only the minimal
gear a head-on ant and a quick farming
run this build is far from optimized the
weapon I'm using doesn't even have
active talent unlocked but the point I'm
trying to make is around the type of
pieces you should be looking out for to
be fair this build is actually more than
what you need to play your part in the
raid there are just a lot of pieces that
we could be further tweaked like a hell
of a lot more health and even more
damage you'll notice straight away this
is very damaged heavy and my attention
to armor and health is quite minimal the
first time around the raid I was
actually using a build with ok damage
and around 300k armor after changing
towards a more glass cannon type build
with no sustain I was worried oh it's
gonna be a little bit too squishy but I
can honestly say I haven't noticed the
difference the enemies had so hard that
my high armor and health were pretty
much being ignored before I get into it
this has been built for PC but i'll be
making suggestions for console as a go
along you should be focusing on the
following when looking at your build
first weapon damage this is a priority
over everything else second damage to
elites if you can get this over 50%
you're doing pretty well
and lastly headshot damage or critical
hit damage and chance if you're on
console here chop damage is actually
less important as you go through the
raid as you'll be facing things that
won't have a hit to shoot like the war
dogs so for this reason focus on weapon
damage and damage to elites first mask
hard-hitting damage to elites there
really isn't another mask talent better
than this one for the raid make sure you
also get the damage to elites attribute
on this piece too as you can get a
fairly high percentage body armor
berserk plus ten percent within damage
for missing 20% of armor depleted I
would usually prefer to run unstoppable
force on this piece but it can be
difficult to activate this talent when
you need it especially if you're in the
role more focused on the turret and the
boss given how hard the enemies hit
you'll often find yourself in low armor
which is where this talent really shines
for this reason I like to run minimal
armor and high health usually you'll
find me running around with no armor at
all gaining another 50% weapon don't
depending on the piece you find you
could also run a second talent with
hard-hitting for more damage to elites
or vital for plus 20% health holster
hard-hitting damage to elites or weapon
damage or precise which is hit shot
damaged or if you're struggling or on
console either critical hit chance or
damage
backpack hard-hitting and on the ropes
for an extra 25 percent weapon damage of
went both of your skills are uncool down
I usually hate this talent because I'm
not a big fan of being forced into using
skills especially if they're there to
keep you alive when needed but in this
situation it's worth it but vital for an
extra 20% health could also be useful
gloves again hard-hitting damage to
elites or weapon damage seeing a trend
here however if you've built up a
certain amount of critical hit chance
clutch could really help you out with a
boost to your health for each critical
hit kneepads for solar PV play
I love patients it's a subtle armor heal
will taking cover but in the raid you
don't often get the chance to stay still
for very long especially in the Boomer
buff stage plus because we want our
armor to actually stay low for berserk
it's good to get rid of this plus any
other armor on kill mods and stared
focus on the same old hard-hitting
damage to elites brand sets if you get
to the point of being able to focus on a
brand set and go down the moon maxing
path continue to look for things that
will assist you with your damage with
anti damage heat shock damage critical
hit damage etc weapons because of the
short period of time you get to dull
damage on boomer and how hard the NPC's
hit focus on burst damage
I prefer assault rifles hard fast damage
with a decent amount of range on console
you may find it easier with the SMG
you'll need to give a little closer but
you'll have the added advantage of
having the built-in critical hit chance
as far as weapon mods and talents follow
the same trend as the riskier build more
damage if I was playing on console I
would ignore the headshot damage and
focus fully on credit damage and chance
but regardless of platform weapon damage
and damage to elites is the first
priority you are very squishy with this
build but given what you're coming up
against a little bit of extra armor
isn't going to help you use cover but
don't sittin up for too long you'll
likely either be flanked or unable to
help the team when taking on the boss
keep moving and bursting any MPC's you
come across although you can't take too
many hits you'll usually be firing at
enemies who are focusing on someone else
there is neat man team use the numbers
to your advantage last but not least
please dear God
when the turret runner calls that boomer
is down
what you're doing and shoot the boss
coming up against boomer you want to be
doing at least 50k damage per assault
rifle bullet but even with this crudely
thrown-together build I've shown above
you should be heading them for a minimum
of ATK per bullet which is more than
enough if you're still struggling with
these numbers it's your team
coordination that's leading you down
this video was really just intended for
some of the crew in the ng and discord
not knowing where to start but there
might be a few others that find this
useful - apologies this video certainly
hasn't followed the same sort of
production quality that I try to achieve
with most but there was a bit of an
urgent need for this one before people
start jumping into the next run of raid
attempts plus I didn't have any raid
footage to go along with it because I
forgot to click the damn record button
hopefully this has been found somewhat
useful for some of you as I said there's
a huge number of options available this
is just one part you could take anyway
let me know if you have any questions
and good luck taking down that big burly
beast Cheers
[Music]
you